en revanche un autre record a été battu
lors de cette vente c'est celui de la
deux chevaux la plus chère du monde la
voiture tout en bois construite par
Michel Robillard a été acheté 210 000
euros frais compris par le Musée des
Arts Forains de Paris ça fabrication
avait demandé 5 ans de travail à ce
menuisier ébéniste à la retraite Aurélie
Renaud a assisté à la vente
au château d'artignies parmi les 146
lots c'est le numéro 6 qui attire les
médias la deux chevaux en bois unique au
monde deux clients par téléphone se
disputent cette oeuvre d'art roulante en
bois fruitier 155
170000 euros les enchères se poursuivent
on renonce Brice
170000 euros trois fois c'est à toi
Michel de tapez
[Musique]
170000 euros pour la vente et 40 000
euros pour les frais la 2 chevaux bat un
record qui était précédemment de 173.000
euros je suis heureux parce qu'on a
battu le record du monde aujourd'hui
donc là deux chevaux la plus chère du
monde c'est quand même un honneur
50 travail plus de 5000 heures c'est une
belle récompense la deux chevaux
fabriquée par Michel Robillard va donc
quitter la Touraine elle a été achetée
par le directeur du Musée des Arts
Forains de Paris et que cette deux
chevaux va continuer de vivre des exposé
à côté des manèges de chevaux de bois et
ces deux chevaux tout en bois et bien
elle avait toute sa place
je vais pas moi j'aurais pas voulu que
ça partait à l'étranger parce que bon
après on perd on sait pas l'histoire
après l'historique ça nous fait un
pincement au cœur de voir qu'elle va
partir de cette guerre déjà
vu que on l'a vu naître d'un autre côté
c'est très bien pour lui que Maka
finisse dans un musée c'est c'est
formidable
Michel Robillard a déjà un autre projet
construire un cabriolet en bois à
l'occasion des 70 ans de la déesse